hello so ladies and gentlemen
this morning so we are organizing a
press point on the consequences
of the death of the young person of hers and the
investigations which have been carried out
in view of the current judicial information
which I will tell you about because
in the press give us the  opportunity to
bring to your attention a certain
number of elements or to confirm a
certain number of elements that you already have
but will not give rise to an exchange, we are
looking at the judicial information which
has just begun
following the death of the  young Naël
who occurred on the morning of June 27, 2023 the
Nanterre public prosecutor's office opened two
flagrant investigations,
one for refusing to comply and
yet i voluntary residence on
no one depositary public authority
what we had already communicated on which
you knew in quest entrusted  at the
Nanterre police station and at the
Hauts-de-Seine territorial security,
moreover, our
investigation for land the leaves
were committed by a depositary of
public authority and this investigation was entrusted
to the IGPN
the objective of these two investigations
distinct and to objectivize all
the circumstances which led to the
death of the young driver of the vehicle
these qualifications were moreover
initially retained by the public prosecutor's office in
the state of the first information
immediately collected on the spot
the elements collected within the framework of
these two procedures consist in particular of
witness hearings, including that of the
passenger who was found to be
exploiting
video surveillance images and amateur videos
broadcast on social networks
requiring various checks,
some of which are still in progress
and of course the statements of the
police  involved who have been heard
on several occasions, including in the
case of a confrontation
as it stands, it is possible to
reconstruct, in view of the elements
available to us at 7 a.m., the course
of the events of this early morning as
follows
after  having taken their service
two motorcyclists of the
territorial company of traffic and
road safety of Hauts-de-Seine which
is a service which depends on the
direction of the public order and the
traffic of the prefecture of police
of Paris
one noticed towards  7:55 a.m. boulevard
Jacques Germain Soufflot in Nanterre
a Mercedes Class A model AMG vehicle
which was registered with a
Polish plate and which was traveling on a
bus lane at high speed in the direction of the
Nanterre University station district
in order to check it we are watching
driving but also the apparent young age
of the occupants of the vehicle, the
two officials tried for the
first time to carry out a check
by activating their sound
and light warning devices, standing at the height of the
vehicle at the level of a red light and
indicating  you know the vehicle
then restart by running the red light
noting the presence of three people on
board this vehicle a front passenger and
a passenger in the right rear the two
police officers therefore followed
this car on several axes of
Nanterre by carrying out  thus a loop
at the level of the human rights roundabout
the vehicle continued its route
opposite rue Pablo Neruda then rough des
trois fontanots and boulevard de pessaro
always followed by the two motorcyclists who
indicated that they had activated their
two-tone again at  targeting their progress by radio
on the airwaves of the police at
8:16 a.m.
during this journey, several
elements including the statements of the
police and the
video surveillance images
show several
violations of the highway code,
in particular crossings of
pedestrian crossings putting in  danger a pedestrian and
a cyclist
take the boulevard de la defense
this vehicle was forced to stop
due to a traffic jam
caused by a marker
dismounting on the side and
behind the Mercedes vehicle the
police claim to have shouted  the
driver to stop by
positioning himself on the left side of the
vehicle
there at the level of the driver's door
the other near the left front fender
he specifies in the context of their
hearings to have both taken out their
weapons and to have them  pointed at the
driver to dissuade him from
restarting by asking him to switch off the
ignition
when the vehicle restarted
the police officer located near the wing of the
vehicle once attracted to the
driver
the vehicle continued on its way passing
through Rago before driving  crashed into an
item of street furniture in Nelson
Mandela Square at 8:19 a.m.
at this time the rear passenger got
out of the vehicle was arrested and the
right front passenger fled
the official who fired the shot
provided first aid to the
drivers and reinforcements
went to the site as well as the
firefighters contacted at 8.21 a.m. who
carried out resuscitation maneuvers
despite his efforts
the death was recorded at 9.15 a.m.
as soon as the investigations decided
by the Nanterre public prosecutor's office opened the shooting police officer
handed over his firearm  service was
transported to the hospital then taken to
the premises of the IGPN to be heard
on the facts
after the first statement the
elements collected at the led to the
placement in police custody of the police
officer of the count of intentional homicide
the deceased minor was  born in 2006 he
was known to the justice services
for acts of refusal to comply the
last having given rise to a
presentation of the minor before the Nanterre prosecutor's office
on Sunday June 25 saw
a summons before the
juvenile court in  September 2023
the police custody of the second passenger
identified was lifted at the beginning
of the afternoon of June 27 after his
hearing, the latter
specified in particular that he had
gotten into the vehicle about
half an hour before the events while  he was
already touring the neighborhood
the third person in the
vehicle is still wanted
support from the emergency service of
the Hauts-de-Seine Aido Victims Association was required
by the prosecution to accompany the
relatives of the deceased who  are going through
dramatic moments
the report of the autopsy carried out
on the morning of June 28 reports death due to
a single shot having crossed the
left arm and the thorax from left to right
additional examinations, particularly in
terms of toxicology, have been ordered
the search of the vehicle did not make it possible to
find dangerous objects or
narcotics inside
the exploitation of the various videos of
the scene was carried out
confirming the declarations of the two
police officers on the course of the vehicle
during the refusal of  to comply but also
that of the second minor passenger
concerning the circulation of the vehicle
in the district
as I indicated it the policeman who is
recognized to have fired was therefore placed in police
custody for intentional homicide the
blood alcohol and consumption screening operations
of narcotics
proved to be negative
during these hearings
the policeman explained his action by the
desire to avoid a new continuation of the
vehicle
by the dangerousness of the
road behavior of the driver
inducing in the policeman the fear that
someone  one either overthrown the fear
of being hit by the vehicle during
its more advanced restart or of seeing
his colleague more advanced in
the passenger compartment of the vehicle injured by the
movement of this car
the second policeman present during the
control one naturally and also
was  heard
both specified during their
hearings that they felt threatened when they
saw the driver restarting,
being close to a wall behind them,
a confrontation was ordered, in
particular on the comments made during the
check and with regard to one of the
amateur videos broadcast  on social networks
only part of the remarks were
recognized by one of the officials the
technical investigations on these
recordings were entrusted to read
CGN in order to specify their content and their
height
in the state of the investigations
and the elements collected the prosecution
considers that the  legal conditions
for the use of the weapon are not met
therefore at the end of his police
custody the police officer implicated for having
used his weapon was torn
today before two
kosasis investigating magistrates within the framework  the
opening of a judicial investigation of the
head of the voluntary residence
with regard to the facts the
need to preserve the
investigations the prosecution has requested the
placement of the police officer responsible for the shooting in
pre-trial detention
the presentation before the
investigating magistrates is in progress
the judicial investigation  should make it possible
to specify the aforementioned elements and
updating elements will
naturally be communicated to you later,
moreover
concerning urban violence,
the department has been familiar with for two nights
the current toll in Hauts-de-Seine
and the following
27 police custody for  the night of June 27 to 28
and 39 police custody for last night
and this for facts of participation
mob degradation of violence
it is done are of particular
gravity
for today alone and
relatively enough done  11 deceases are carried out,
including three
immediate appearances, in particular for people who
have broadcast videos of police officers
on social networks or the
contact details of the police officer in question.
It should be noted that concerning the
events of last night, several
damages to useful goods  public
have been committed
I particularly note
the fire last night of the
local court Daniel which gives an investigation
entrusted to the judicial police I
remind you that it is a local court
whose vocation is to deal with the
situations of our fellow citizens most
in difficulty  which has thus been targeted,
the public prosecutor's office has been fully mobilized on
this crisis since its origin and
has been very attentive to the
judicial treatment of these offences,
some offenses of which incur penalties of
up to 10 years' imprisonment
here too some updating elements
will be communicated later thank you
I told you at the moment that I was
not answering the questions then we
have an opening of
judicial information in progress and that it is too
early to communicate on its points thank
you